was geht ab ihr sopran ii und heute gibt
es mal wieder ein ründchen jump down
weil das irgendwie zum reden cooles habe
ich beim letzten mal festgestellt
ich möchte heute einfach tatsächlich mal
über ein paar unterschiedliche themen
reden die mir auf tour da vorgeschlagen
wurden also nicht so cool video sondern
einfach mal meine meinung zu themen die
ihr gerne hören wollt also auch gute
tage nicht mehr gerne auch zu
irgendwelchen politischen oder sonstwas
themen aber erst mal fragt der liebe
paluccas wirst du den minecraft story
mode bzw andere story displays machen in
nächster zeit und ich muss sagen dass
ich dumm dass mir das tatsächlich gut
vorstellen könnte den minecraft story
mode weniger aber andere soria space
hätte ich grundsätzlich bock drauf
einfach damit ich mal irgendwie was habe
so einen ein slot pro woche was
vielleicht auch nicht bei allen so gut
ankommt aber das ist einfach mal
ausprobieren kann weil ich einfach mal
lust drauf habe okay der einheit schon
gewonnen man ja mal lust drauf habe das
auszuprobieren
es geht jetzt auch übrigens gar nicht
darum dass ich hier der krasseste bin
und unbedingt gewinnen möchte sondern
einfach mal fand das habe ich auch
fahren aber ja ich habe mir die fragen
mit dem hashtag gerät mal max stellen
lassen und luca take that x max willst
du der maxime eine rot malt fließt notar
geht weil gerade eben hatten gesehen wie
ich mich gelegt habe und so könnte mir
vorstellen dass das die meter hinterher
gerannt sind
das war das wahrscheinlich hat einfach
zufällig wie wird sich youtube für dich
ändern falls du mit der schule fertig
bis zum studieren musste und so weiter
darauf freue ich mich schon dass ich mit
der schule fertig bin weil ich dann
wahrscheinlich auch wie soll es anders
sein richtung köln
weil es jetzt einfach cool ist somit den
ganzen leuten zusammenarbeiten zu können
es macht mir eigentlich spaß und dann
hätte ich auch mal zeit mich irgendwie
aufwendigen projekten zu widmen
also ich habe damals du draußen zeiten
so eine cherry gehabt einfach solche
sachen also aufrichtigen richtig guten
schiri zu machen ich sage das wort die
häufig aber herz also das ist schon cool
darauf habt ihr eigentlich lust dann
nach köln zu ziehen und man diese frauen
die ganzen leute einen so oft runter
wieso rennen nicht einfach alle rundum
probieren das universum
dann werde viel schneller alle da ja ja
ja ja ist es schwer als youtube
neueinsteiger
ich würde sagen es wird nicht leichter
aber wobei man muss auch sehen es gibt
jetzt viel mehr leute youtube schon
davor haben halt weniger leute geschaut
und war also wenig leute geschaut wenig
leute konnten stecken jetzt macht noch
mehr leute und mehr leute können
entdecken so aber es ist trotzdem nach
wie vor schwierig aber ich glaube
eigentlich fest daran dass sich guter
content durchsetzen kann
also wenn jemand was richtig gutes macht
dann und dabei bleibt dann
da wüsste ich nicht was dagegen spricht
dass die leute erfolgreich werden es
gibt auch immer wieder leute die
erfolgreich werden ohne besonders gute
sachen zu machen aber ich glaube wenn
man richtig guten konnte macht dann wird
man auch erfolgreich weil da muss man
irgendwie dafür noch mal glück haben
irgendwann hat man glück dass
irgendjemand das sieht was man macht
wenn das gut ist dann könnte mir gut
vorstellen
weichert klappte ja dritter platz
schlich wenn man dass du das gut macht
was man macht dann wird man irgendwann
auch dafür die anerkennung bekommen die
man verdient kraftvoll viele vorschläge
deine meinung zur homophobie etc ja
meine meinung dazu seien homophobie ist
natürlich schwachsinn nicht jeder soll
die im wenn er will
und ich finde es lächerlich wenn man
anderen leuten vorschreiben möchte wen
sie zu leben haben was unnatürlich ist
oder gegen den willen gottes oder
irgendwo eine kacke lächerlich also ich
hoffe mal dass das klar war dass ich da
nicht irgendwie komisch einstellen dass
ich da so eine offene schnell zu habe
weil ich finde es einfach dumm wenn
leute das anders also wenn ihr wenn wenn
leute einfach
da irgendwas vorschreiben wollen wir das
ist einfach ein witz er verfolgte mich
ja ich glaube das ist der typ der mark
hat auch schon der erste mal dabei
vielleicht bilde ich mir ein
so finde es komisch dass es mau aus
schäfer gibt das nicht wir machen das ja
auch wir spielen wir ein bisschen mit
luca und ich das ist also ist jetzt
einfach krass ich hätte gedacht ich
würde sterben
die spieler auch wie gesagt ein bisschen
mit also das ist nicht komisch dass das
gibt wette gewonnen
ich bin dritter platz das ist cool was
hältst du von maus und was ist dann mit
martina ach so bei martina ich martina
und luft ich finde ich super
merkt ihr irgendwie voll maut fokussiert
ich wollte mal so richtig mit
irgendwelchen ganzen tiefen hat und das
könnte warum herrscht gerät mal max
überschuhe gerne ich mag schulen
ich weiß nicht wer das nicht weiß
natürlich kaufen relativ gerne sneaker
andere leute sagen so zum beispiel mein
bruder was ich dass eine leasingrate
stecken soll das geld des tiger aber
nein ich hab mir das mega ja keine
ahnung ich finde das cool
also ich weiß nicht ich liebe das wir
nicht wenn man einfach frisch aussieht
wenn man seine klappe wird gut blieb es
nicht
aber wenn man einfach so einen aufstand
hat man die perfekt passenden sneaker
dass ich doch sehr schön so über
fanfiction auch ein interessantes thema
bei klar bin ich so geteilter meinung
findest du ganz lustig irgendwie aber
andererseits
ist es auch verdammt strange dass es
sowas überein gibt man stelle mir vor
über euch schreibt sich eine dritte
person irgendwelche geschichten wie er
mit euren eigenen freunden irgendwelche
66 und sowas macht und das ist kann
schon sehr befremdlich sein wenn man so
fanfiction ließ aber an sich ich mein
ich find's lustig wenn die leute spaß
dabei hat sie zu lesen und zu schreiben
dann ist das auch alles cool was sind
deine lieblingstiere ich hatte das sind
was dein lieblingstier ich hatte noch
nie ein haus hier und mein lieblingstier
ist würde ich sagen
irgendwas kleines weil ich würde ja mal
von einem hund gebissen und deshalb
eigentlich keine allzu große tiere mehr
als zehn stichen genäht werden
klasse schmerzensgeld bekommen aber sie
war zehn irgendwie 1500 euro
schmerzensgeld bekommen die zehn jahren
und habe das fleißig investiert in
konsolen fast food so wie ich jetzt auch
noch mache nur dass sie nicht wissen
würde ich sagen wir wieder beißen lassen
es lohnt sich auf jeden fall leute lasst
euch von hunden beißen gestorben bin du
hast du fahren nochmal eine
signierstunde macht habe ich doch beim
frage antwort wie schon gesagt falls
nichts geplant wenn was kommt dann das
euch natürlich sobald es geht wissen
erzähl mal was über die mag ich bin 18
ich mache mein abitur und werde gerade
von jungen typen verfolgt so mailath der
kleine stromer jetzt hier dann welche
auf java solche sehen ich meine bist
auch schon relativ ihr habt die
möglichkeit etwas zu fragen und sagt man
erzählt machtvoll und fertig das wissen
um dein leben noch alles machen
also ich würde mir wünschen dass ich
einfach immer zufrieden bin
nur das meer ist es gar nicht was ihre
wünsche man ich bin dumm läuft so
wahrscheinlich wir noch irgendwelche
besseren tagen haben bei diesen ist ein
bisschen geht man über die ganze
derzeitige politische lage denke da kann
man recht viel über dinge nicht so nicht
sonderlich konkret der vorschlag aber ja
ich finde das ist alles relativ
schwierig zurzeit die lage aber ich
meine politik ist immer relativ
schwierig das irgendwie so dass im
grünen politik dass man nicht einfach so
dahinter blicken kann
hey man kann an lucky seien voll uncool
dass man nicht immer dahinter blicken
kann aber ich finde es sehr sehr dumm
dass so viel aggressivität zurzeit
in der welt ist so also jetzt aber auch
nahostkonflikt ist derselbe aber auch
hier russland usa und sohn jett finde
ich nicht cool das ist also viel zu viel
ärger einfach nicht weil ich meine wenn
man irgendwas gelernt aus der
vergangenheit dann dass frieden cooler
ist als krieg oder also das ist schon
hart um finde ich irgendwie falls das
volk endlich formuliert aber an sich ist
das ja ja ja leute wollen dass sie über
youtube deutschland rede vom typ
deutschland eigentlich ganz cool wobei
ich im moment mehr spaß aber
amerikanische youtube videos zu schauen
ausgenommen tv gerne also wirklich
schwanger wie in dienstag einfach
irgendwie immer denke sie als video
da bin ich irgendwie ich bin kein fanboy
aber ich finde einfach den content
richtige
aber das ist auf jeden fall cool und
zusammen uns noch zwei themen raus würde
ich sagen bist du aktuell keinen kanal
zufrieden nicht so wirklich
aber da möchte ich auf jeden fall was
wir machen was sie tippen bin rede mal
über seine schulzeit lustige stories und
oder peinliche geschichten oder so für
dich könnte die nächsten tage was
interessant kommen weil ich habe mir
überlegt dass in format mache aber das
habe ich ja schon gesagt wo ich mir
private freunde einlade und das sind
haben fachleute tier nicht kennt
verfasst glaub ich hab sogar noch weiter
gestiegen
da sind leute die ihr nicht kennt
sondern privat freunde die noch nie auf
youtube waren größtenteils denke ich mal
und dann erzählen wir einfach bei einer
runde fifa oder sonst was also irgendwie
so was ich wissen
der gast darf sich das spiel aussuchen
erzähle ich dann einfach eine story oder
wie es hieß soll die uns beide verbindet
also dannzumal xbox oder keine ahnung
habe ich noch nie gemacht aber irgendwie
keine ahnung wie man zusammen schule
geschwänzt haben oder so ein chat oder
einen unfall gebaut oder irgendwie sowas
ist ja also darauf hab ich auf jeden
fall lust und ich glaube das ist auch
mal interessant weil man kennt ja die
ganzen leute irgendwie so von youtube
und dann habt ihr mal jede woche ein tag
wo jemand neues kennenlernen ok jetzt
ist es vorbei
eine frage noch ausbilden so
flüchtlingskrise überforderung der
regierung und sorgen der einheimischen
have fun
die fragestellerin weiß auch dass das
ein sehr umfangreiches thema ist bzw
der fragesteller ich weiß nicht ob das
ein fake gekonntes aber
ja ich finde auf jeden fall dass man ich
finde es werden die hätte man auf
europäischer ebene lösen müssen oder
angehen müssen
die frage was mit den flüchtlingen
passiert weil wählt man hätte das
vielleicht einfach fair verteilen können
jeden und dann werden jetzt nicht so in
einigen ländern so probleme aufgetreten
aber ja ich weiss nicht also ich tue auf
jeden fall ein bisschen was die spende
und ich glaube man kann da kann ein
jeder kann ein bisschen was helfen ja
dann würde ich sagen was auch vom
heutigen video einfach lagern schwach
eigentlich wollte ich nicht mehr so an
trotzdem verdammt viel spaß macht das
reden einfach und dann kommt vielleicht
morgen wenn ein bisschen mehr zeit habe
mal wieder irgendetwas wo ich was
zusammen schneide und lass mir wissen
wir bock auf dieses konzept habe mit
freunden da müssen wir mal ein game
capture card besorgen und ich habe mike
habe ich da noch dieser anstieg mikrofon
bis zum nächsten mal macht's gut